ah Bonjour - limo Bienvenue - the Monday
morning podcast Faludi June de suite
2018 what's going on how are you how's
your Monday treating you over there in
the states I got my last couple of days
over here in Paris I'm psyched to come
back I'm sad that it's over I had a
wonderful time thank you to everybody
over here
that put up with my my horrible [ __ ]
French you know I know I just I just I
just stayed in the by punished him with
it this time
okay and if they didn't like it somebody
taught me something to say they'll just
say about to fan kuai that means go [ __ ]
yourself vaatu Fei are cool cool a cue
lights aren't cute
are cool a uncool a far too fair uncool
a Monsieur with you
vous parlez Abu far too fair until a
Monsieur you gotta throw in the mister
still be polite you know what I mean you
can tell somebody to go [ __ ] themselves
over here but when you're wearing a
scarf you gotta throw them most you you
know so you don't seem like an animal
alright oh I've learned that you know
it's the hardest one to say to say
streak right over here it's ru e Roo but
you gotta go whole rule rules sound on
are a nice year are we on - Fay I'm cool
yay I'm Q day I'm cool eh I'll get it
I'll get it done I'll learn how to say
go [ __ ] yourself in a new language now
right before we get started a very
special thanks to a very special person
and a wonderful comedian and equally as
well human being mr. Tom Rhodes for
hooking me up he found out I was in
Pattie and he was like are you still
there I said we he said ah
yeah you need to go to this [ __ ]
patisserie they have the best [ __ ]
sandwiches and blah blah blah blah and
goddamnit the man was right best
sandwiches I've had over here maybe top
[ __ ] two or three sandwiches I've
ever had in my [ __ ] life and then I
had one of those little macaron those
little [ __ ] cookies they made a giant
one it was pistachio it was [ __ ]
incredible you don't food so good you
start having Tourette's as you're eating
it just above [ __ ] sure I was doing that
was unbelievable [ __ ] eatin is looking
around for people that let them know you
know I know what you're gonna say what's
the name of it bill
what is the name of the patisserie over
there and Perry and I only have one
thing to say to you far too fair and
cool eh I'm not [ __ ] telling you cuz
I don't want to I don't like standing in
lines
alright become a [ __ ] comedian but
friend Tom Rhodes and maybe he'll tell
you okay but what I ate today was was
magic alright and I've been enough
around enough magicians in this business
to know that you never revealed the
trick okay Tom Road showed me the trick
okay it's his trick his walking it's his
joint oh my god
it was [ __ ] unbelievable I walked a
mile and a half over there and and back
it's my workout in the morning I just go
for a brisk walk you know I'm starting
to learn how to use those little places
where people jog along the sin I go down
there so I don't have to deal with the
[ __ ] giant groups of people crossing
the street to go to the North Road am I
actually actually went in the we went in
that church and I'm glad I did it the
line moves really quickly you go in
there you're like wow this is this is
huge this is scary these statues not a
lot of positive messages in them what a
misery a lot of death a lot of weeping
but I think that that's just sort of the
vibe back then I mean people just people
[ __ ] died back there
you know not liked it not today people
just they live for [ __ ] ever you know
I mean at my age I see somebody died 70s
I got [ __ ] what happened what did he eat
no it's too soon do back then you you
[ __ ] you went outside and like a
mosquito bit you and then the whole
village died
the second you sneezed everybody was
just done you know and I believe it was
some pompous [ __ ] that said art imitates
life so if everybody over this dying and
you're really good with your hands when
you get to clean it there what do you
think you're gonna make you're gonna
make some [ __ ] miserable statues
you know I'll tell you these these these
[ __ ] people around here walking
around these pasty white kids thinking
that they're goth okay with their black
nails and lipstick and all of that
[ __ ] let me tell you something you
got nothing on some of these statues
they're in the North Road Dom so you
don't have to say to all you got kids
out there unto faith I'm doing aren't
you late I thought get up every time
whatever that's what you do you just
punish people punish people with your
[ __ ] I ran into some guy wasn't
violently what the [ __ ] I was some guy
from Washington not DC the state right
and he was talking about trying to learn
French over here who's living over here
he said it's brutal man he goes they
just you know you try to speak it to
them then they just start speaking
English and I told myself I go punish
him with it I don't give a [ __ ] if they
do the whole thing in [ __ ] English
you stay you stay in the pocket right
stay on target that Star Wars [ __ ] did I
tell you guys that why actually on the
plane I watched one of these plane rides
I took I watched that one of those one
of those Star Wars movies Laura Dern f
is for families Laura Dern was in it
the woman who played Princess Leia I
believe it was the last movie she did
before unfortunately she passed away I
don't know who else was it a bunch of
young people all right kids
kids to me kids to me are under the age
of 39 at this point and I I really
enjoyed it and I'd like to apologize to
anybody I may have offended at economic
con I don't remember what the movie was
called oh there was an Luke Scott Mark
Hamill was it it right and at the end of
the movie right I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm kidding
like you nerds haven't watched at nine
million times you know weeping into a
potato sack whatever you know I liked
how he was wearing the Ben Kenobi
[ __ ] like you know it really the
messages in Star Wars you know that if
you actually live a righteous life you
know that there's really no money in it
the way the whole game set up and you
end up in like a burlap sack for a
bathrobe just living by yourself you
know making rocks levitate you know for
tourists or whatever the [ __ ] it is he
was doing on that island but if you sell
your [ __ ] soul to the dark side you
know you get that dope ass outfit that
[ __ ] Darth Vader had you know that
looks like some [ __ ] what's-his-face
would have designed who is that kusa
designer over here in France
he used to be fat and now he isn't and
all he does his [ __ ] on fat people and
he won't make clothes for fat people
hey Nia what's the name of the designer
over here he's hilarious he used to be
fat and now we have and now we are see
like I said we've been on vacation to
one hey Nia I'm gonna fail again on
coupon 2qa I came huge qutilat' yes I'm
telling to to do that because I know you
and you're familiar what's the name of
that what's the name of that uh
look robotoid what's his name who's Lou
Grover died I don't know did they sign a
white-haired guy you used to be fat Oh
Karl Lagerfeld
yeah it doesn't Darth Vader suit look
like some [ __ ] he'd come up with oh yeah
there you go
I [ __ ] nailed it you're impressed
with some of my fashion knowledge you've
been I've been proving yourself to be
quite the passion you stay out here I
was telling told you the difference
between the Hori style and the elegant
style right yes thanks for explaining
that to me what do you mean you actually
were fascinated by it right we went to
lunch and we were talking about how some
of the girls were like very elegant and
some you know some are all instagrammy
mm-hmm it's desperate like they would
like basically the fashion version of a
comic with the catchphrase right yes
exactly
posed to me who's all pure up there with
my [ __ ] and dick jokes yeah yeah the
comedian's comedian that's you I was
gonna bust in here and see what you were
talking about you jerk what's going on
I'll tell you what's going on what
yesterday probably Father's Day yeah my
second doozy him are we that way I we
went to the vaunt katas lemma we went to
the 24 Hours of LeMans how'd you enjoy
it for hours
no but it's not always like that
sometimes it is that sometimes
[Music]
okay
who's that yeah but like what so are you
just waiting for somebody to crash or
like what's the cause it's just round
and round she goes where she stops
nobody knows it's like you know like it
wasn't that exciting I mean I I know
that it's a big it's a world famous was
it cooled at least see cars going that
fast that close to each other you know
seeing cars goes fast before and it
doesn't really do that much for me for
me this is what's [ __ ] hilarious it
was Father's Day Formula One with you
because Kenya because if you sitting in
the stands and they just [ __ ] drove
in a straight line it would be over in a
minute so that's why they go around and
around and around and then they would
also have to clear out you know for a
500-mile race if they had to clear out
500 miles of streets in a straight
direction I mean all the sudden you
can't go much different book and the
other side of text please know how on
horse racing and I'm not saying that
like horse racing is OK but you know how
it's like go baby go and everyone's like
yeah yeah like she like let's go let's
go baby go there wasn't a lot of that
like people were on their phones people
were eating crepes like it was very like
subdued like there wasn't it doesn't
feel like there was a lot of action
going on a lot of excitement is why I'm
saying cuz it was a 24 hour race maybe
too long like maybe they shouldn't I
would say this what I thought I was
amazing to me is that they had I I
counted out saying there's got to be at
least two classes if not three classes
of cars out there turns out there was
four different clusters so I think there
was like four winners in each class one
for each class but we got there on the
second day so when we showed up there
was two cars in the lead lap both
Toyota's and the guy in first place was
ahead by like a minute and a half which
is like a you know that's like
the back of the race and anything else
and then the guy in the third place was
12 laps down so I was kind of like out
so this thing we there's three hours to
go and this is already over unless
somebody crashes or has a problem with
their car and the toyota in second place
did have a problem with this car briefly
which put him even further back then he
was down two laps and then so yeah it's
more of like an endurance thing I
thought it was fascinating because if I
would recommend if you go to it go for
this start or I would go at night just
to see him at night it was kind of cool
to see the brake lights and wipers and
[ __ ] I've never seen that on race cars
he's usually just like it's just a shell
for a body with a roll behold roll cage
and it's just the power train that's it
so it was exciting to see windshield
wipers yeah it was for me I'm you know
you know it's funny no no no no you know
what it is yes Steve McQueen and all
that [ __ ] it was it was and just to know
how many people have died and the balls
that it takes and all that [ __ ] to do it
and I gotta be honest with you you know
we were driving out there you were
listening to you beyond saying you jay-z
that we got there and you were on your
phone the entire [ __ ] time and it
made me feel good about that time I
walked out when you were you you said
you were quote in this play um first of
all that is not the same thing how dare
you even make that comparison and I'll
make it again don't you yell at me on my
own phone the whole time I was taking
Instagram video of you okay and answer
Kopu you and of myself and the race I
was on the whole entire time and I
didn't walk out okay I wasn't like
alright I'll be in the car and say the
same thing about that play I'd sat
through the first half of it were you in
the 24 Hours of LeMans
are you in it were you driving and I was
dead no it's not the same thing I think
it's the same it was the
the narrator of that show and you walked
out because you were like bored and it
was so rude and it really hurt my feet
of you I did it I cannot believe no you
didn't you did it for entirely selfish
reason you were sitting right in my line
of you and then we come back from
intermission and you're [ __ ] gone I
can't even believe there was a white guy
rapping and it was a plane it's the two
worst things ever combined and I stand
to win 90 minutes of it and you were a
better actor than anybody there and all
they handed you was going later at the
Hall of Justice it annoyed me I can't
even believe that you would bring that
up so many years later how long have you
known me I'm gonna bring that up so many
years later after this you really are
like the king of bringing back stuff
well yeah remember back when and it's
like we've been together for 15 years
you're literally bringing up something
from like year two what else do I bring
up from way back when like a lot of
stuff oh good point yeah you're the king
of making a big statement and then you
can't back it up
that's the [ __ ] point of it is I am
the goddamn King oh good one yeah take
that to the bank
Cassius no I get no auto racing is a
torturous thing to bring to somebody who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about cars but we
really understand how they work we met
that really nice guy Ryan hilly and he's
don't want to taught me how to say go
[ __ ] yourself what's that Brian he was
really nice he was very nice and he
helped me out my phone's mm-hm
I enjoy I can't believe I went there oh
this is a great one so Nia doesn't like
beer there's no wine there so I keep
buying two beers and it's like oh you
don't want to finish that Salam drink
daddy's having a good time on Father's
Day right so I bought a UH crepes there
but no wine I mean as as France but that
truly was a grapes to them it's just
such a [ __ ] sandwich
yeah that's sure that was really kind of
what about the other guy isn't is it
insulting if I say that it's like the
NASCAR France that's insulting
right because NASCAR is not on the same
level as 24-hour oh I don't know what
you mean I think that you were more
looking at it like you were outside
Paris so there wasn't as many fancy
close to people walking around I think
that that's what it is you're very you
you know you're a class kind of person
like oh right here you're there no no
I'm up here I'm not classes or elitist
and I can't we're not gonna think I'm
not building that because people are all
my comments being like oh I hope you
were nice to the waiter oh well they
didn't busy well like you know what do
they say to me could you be nicer to do
you do they say that
yeah when every [ __ ] week let me say
I want to see I want the receipts do you
want the receipts
well I'm on [ __ ] receipts then I'll
show you myself come at me like you're
the FBI you're not gonna turn over my
laptop to you yes we did we had a great
time over here and tonight we are seeing
guns that roses mm-hmm tonight hold a
candle in the girl November rain good
thank you I've never seen them a concert
it's gonna be awesome so that's what
we're doing and then we're gonna like in
and then we fly back I hope he says that
how do you say that in French anyway I
don't know I've been having a good time
I've been torturing people with my
French haven't I yeah I don't when they
go to English I don't give a [ __ ] it's
like it's the most fun it's so much
[ __ ] fun to just people humor you but
a lot of times a leg can't be bothered
remember when um Oh remember what was
the restaurant we went to
we were having a hard time figuring out
the menu and I was saying to the guy I
asked him I said oh can you translate
some of this stuff for us and he goes oh
why don't I just get you an English menu
and I was like okay you were like oh no
no I want to know explain it's like Bill
he doesn't want us to hear and translate
the entire menu was in English Bay
how does parents make their money
tourists buy oh yeah [ __ ] humor me
okay but it doesn't work like that you
come over to my country you did that you
know [ __ ] it down the street there I
know they're all [ __ ] don't don't
pull that [ __ ] I'm so sick of hearing
that every [ __ ] person who isn't from
America is [ __ ] is is the greatest
person ever I'm walking right now hang
on a second yeah I got to go get my
charger here when we're walking I'm
always always spinning always moving
Kyle Dunnigan um I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is no no I don't I don't do that
okay people here in France are just like
Americans okay some of them are nice
some of them are not and a lot of them
are fat okay yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ] fat Peter I'll be okay okay okay
I'm done again you genius all right do
you have anything else to add about how
you know okay here's the thing all right
so maybe you didn't do it to the level
of walking out halfway through a play
with I want to reiterate again just in
defense to my listeners it was a play
and there was a white guy rapping the
entire time okay and it was an Eminem Oh
eyebrows up like he was blowing my mind
i sat through ninety minutes to that as
you sat over in the [ __ ] corner
because like later paging mrs. Herman
mr. Herbert you have a phone call at the
front desk directions because it wasn't
a full production it was kind of like a
REIT staged reading so I was it was a
musical I don't think so you know I was
there doing the stage direction
I got paid it was a gig I don't think
okay okay [ __ ] out of you I didn't make
you Wow I didn't walk out if I went out
and I had a Sam Adams and I was like and
I came back wait let me finish a nice
ending [ __ ] that was delicious
mm-hmm that was as delicious as what I
just saw was horrific
and I was just like maybe if I stay out
here she won't notice it was totally
totally selfish and I have apologized
and then because because of the guilt no
no that I try to bring you down to my
level
oh because I love you so much how
pleased and it changed me that you know
just because you know I do all these
great things for you yeah what I learned
it from I don't know I'm not gonna you
cry on cue Oh God did you try be sassy
yeah okay see I just felt like I was
doing it did they rebuild good times
what just happened there I'm not sure
mama
we'll be right back with white red black
Nene after these [ __ ] messages anyway
red white red all right are you gonna
miss this department I'm ready to go
home after the the Guns N'Roses thing is
going to be it's perfect
we're gonna do that and then we [ __ ]
go home I'm ready to go back eat some
quinoa get back on my diet hit the
elliptical
oh you mean having croissants and
baguettes every day
that's so [ __ ] good yeah but you
don't get as fat as if you eat them over
there you know who makes them Howard
Johnson who makes them in our country
who makes the bag
have really good instruments Entenmann's
pepperidge farm there's some good places
that have amazing croissants but no not
like here okay alright well thank you
for coming out let me let me finish this
[ __ ] thing oh you're not dad huh
nom only 23 minutes and this is you what
usually when I when I butcher Oh God
[Music]
when you told me to come in here look at
you walking out on the podcast the way I
did on your play case I guess we're even
now
oh my god Obama done oh god dude the
[ __ ] play was that [ __ ] play was
the worst [ __ ] key dupa dupa dupa do
with dopey dopey
he got depe dude doing the [ __ ] thing
with his hands uh it was it was it
wasn't a bomb how [ __ ] long he's
supposed to sit there for that you know
and she gets to go to a goddamn car race
and [ __ ] sit there and look up
Dancing with the Stars [ __ ] as I'm
sitting they should clearly bored out of
her [ __ ] mind bored out of her
[ __ ] mind at that [ __ ] race tough
like [ __ ] shoe leather that moves
around
alright where the [ __ ] is it advertising
for this you know I'll never live down
that I knew it you know it's so [ __ ]
stupid is if I just went back in for the
final 90 [ __ ] minutes
I'm the kiddin of bringing up [ __ ] how
many times she's [ __ ] brought that up
to me
put it this way I'm getting yelled at
that longer than the [ __ ] play was
alright
please don't read on air
[Music]
this is a note from somebody host says
he doesn't know what he's saying and at
the end he offers advice that directly
contradicts what he read they just asked
that you not imply something okay right
right all right everybody [ __ ] relax
Jesus Christ him okay it's not about
giving people information it's about it
being entertaining
all right policy genius if you have a
car at what you miss you you have car
insurance if you have a home that Meisel
remembers that you have home insurance
if you are alive shouldn't you have life
insurance four out of ten people don't
have life insurance at all it's not
their fault it's not light it's life
insurance is fault
shopping for life insurance is confusing
and it takes forever
so Paulie genius made it AG Poli genius
is the easy way to compare life
insurance online in just five minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it's that simple
in fact Poli policy oh not Poli gene
policy genius it's the greatest policy
ever has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance and placed over
twenty billion dollars in coverage and
then it'll make life and and they don't
make just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
you've been putting off getting life
insurance don't put it off any longer
you got to do this stuff by the way
especially you got a wife and family you
know you got kids and [ __ ] you got to do
it it's the greatest feeling ever I know
it's weird you know contemplating your
own mortality but after you did it you
got that a you know if I die everybody's
gonna be good be a [ __ ] cake party
it's a great feeling unless you're
married to a psycho it's never been
easier to buy and REITs are a 20-year
low policy genius.com
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance pol I see why
and I US policy genius.com
if you guys seen that stupid commercial
where that woman is just like going you
know I had insurance on my car and you
know when my wrecked my car they only
gave me you know I paid 12 grand for my
car and it's five years later and they
only gave me six for what am I supposed
to do by half a car no you had the wrong
insurance I love it they act like you
know there's two types of insurance you
can get insurance the cheaper kind which
is they're gonna give you the money for
the value of whatever the [ __ ] it is
that you insured at that time what it is
at that time depreciate it or you can
buy replace it new and that's gonna cost
you way more [ __ ] money
so that woman is yelling at the
insurance company and the reality is is
she's [ __ ] naive well she's just an
actor whoever wrote that [ __ ] thing
is it's it's like this this new
insurance company that is now you know
gonna [ __ ] give you a 12 grand for
your $12,000 car ten years after your
body you're gonna [ __ ] pay for that
alright it's gonna cost a lot of money
and if you add up what the [ __ ] you paid
for it over the years it's it's really
probably not that much of a difference
okay simply safe everybody it's
important to protect your home with the
home security system how can we protect
your home and your privacy that's what
you're gonna love about simply safe they
obsess over details like no home
security company here's an example
simply safe has a camera you can control
from your phone but they want to protect
your home and your privacy so they came
up with this brilliant idea a privacy
shutter for their camera now simply safe
what is it you to be able to hear the
shutter clicks so you know it's closed
they want to it to have a light on it so
you can easily tell when it's on they
needed it to work the entire lifespan of
the system
so simply safe got to work bum bum bum
bum bum bum all the testing different
metal ball and hinge designs for months
and months does that mean like door
hinges
we gotta make it stop squeaking about
the Papa the result an effective home
security camera with a thin lightweight
aluminum privacy ship that will make
every double work every time it's that
kind of attention to detail that sets
simply safe apart and keeps your family
safe simply save isn't just home
security it's home security done right
checkout simply say today it's simply
safe bird calm that's simply say bird
calm to learn more about sip be safe
today Hey
simply safe comets s I am PL I sa Fe
Burt calm all right there you go all
right now where did all my questions go
who a monk my shelves alright so anyways
follow my god I made such anyone I made
such a [ __ ] ass of myself I've eaten
so much French food okay I got [ __ ]
baguettes coming out of my fork any is
over here and I'm growing a [ __ ]
beret well my hair used to be okay
better it was doable so I up the street
they had this they had a little pizzeria
so I'm like okay there's no way there's
pizza can be as bad as the pizza in LA
you know I know it's not could be as
good as Italy who gives a [ __ ] right so
I'm trying to find this place and what
happens when you're in a country where
you don't speak the language is a lot of
times you stop reading words and you
just start looking at colors of things
and you start like like anything yellow
is a taxi anything blue becomes a police
card like that type of [ __ ] so there was
this restaurant with this red awning
like the Italian restaurant and I'm
looking at it going I don't know man
this doesn't quite look right and rather
than just reading the French what is it
Britta Surrey or something like that
whatever I went up to the guy and I was
just looking at the menu and I was just
you know I was just tired and I couldn't
find any pizzas anything so finally I
just this guy walks up to one of the
[ __ ] ways is like you know Bonjour
Monsieur but dinner I am Susan wah is
this
to tell you in restaurant and he just
likes girls like oh he's like no
Monsieur this is a French restaurant
it just [ __ ] to me walked away felt
like such an [ __ ]
what is it Brasserie whatever it means
it was written right there across the
red awning and then it went one more
block up and there's the red awning that
was the Italian place and I wanted to
yell death excuse yeah I was only off by
a block go [ __ ] yourself
but I know he was right and I went in
and I ordered two pieces right I got the
margarita and then I got the one with
the anchovies on it and I got to tell
you it was [ __ ] horrific worse than
the pizza in LA but the salade niçoise
was uh famous was actually delicious but
um I might have Indian food tonight I
just I can't [ __ ] do it anymore
I stayed here just a couple of days too
long but I got to see guns and roses you
want to hear my whole [ __ ] Guns and
Roses story here okay
the first time they came around in a
city that I was in they were opening for
Motley Crue the original lineup and I
forget why I [ __ ] missed that show
all right and then then they use Your
Illusion tour came out and I had a
ticket to see him on that one and then
one of my buddies you know the love of
his life dumped him and he was [ __ ]
devastated borderline suicidal and he
needed some sort of [ __ ] light in his
life so I said hey I got a ticket to
Guns & Roses you go you need it because
I don't want to see you kill yourself
and he said I appreciate that man and
then you know all the drama happened you
know and all the you know the whole band
basically was just Axl right and then
they didn't talk for like 10 12 years or
something like that and by then I was a
comedian I just stayed oh and then when
they got back together I had a hookup to
go to the show at the [ __ ] club there
that
troubadour their first time back
together I had a ticket for that but I
was working on the road I couldn't go
every [ __ ] time I've tried to see
this band one of my favorite bands of
all [ __ ] time I just something has
always happened where I haven't been
able to go so finally finally I'm going
to see him tonight I can't [ __ ] wait
it's gonna be yeah that's not even gonna
be real until it starts happening that's
how long I've been waiting to see this
friggin bin so anyways
very excited about that and I'm also a
great way to wind up a perfect trip and
then get back to the states and do some
stand-up because I have not done
stand-up in a couple of weeks old
[ __ ] rusty Jones is gonna limp
onstage down the comedy store later on
this weekend probably try to get my
[ __ ] act back together so anyways
let's uh my daughter has to take a nap
my lovely daughter she's so cute she
could say all these French words now we
ball Bonjour
why isn't this light working I can't
even see any time I've done here alright
let's just read a couple of questions
here ah von Kant l'amour 24 Hours of
LeMans limo hey Billy bourguignon I just
heard you say you were going to a little
mall for the race I'm from Cleveland but
was able to go to the 24 hours twice
when I happen to be in France for work
the same week not sure what your plans
are there but had to let you know about
an awesome hidden gem along the must
Lane Strait my first time there 2012 a
friend came out to meet me and we drove
down the with essentially no plans
didn't have tickets or a place to stay
that night we bought tickets at the gate
and got in just in time for the start
then ended up befriending and drinking
with the group of Brits that lasted most
of the day ah this is how you do it one
of the outlets who want me to do the
next time one of them told us of a bar
somewhere along the no way the
ridiculously long straight that runs a
few miles away from the
area of the track you get access to oh
you get access to with the tickets on
him and the two of us decided to leave
the track and catch a cab to try finding
it took forever seeking it out though
random backroads the streets you would
usually get to it are on wait the street
you would usually get to it on is the
racetrack found out after the fact the
place is called I can't read this
I'll bearish down there and was a great
spot to eat drink while catching a short
glimpse of cars at top speed just before
the first chicane I would definitely
recommend seeking it out if possible but
also I learned on my second trip there a
few years later you should definitely
make a reservation maybe it's not so
hidden anymore because it was too
crowded to get in and they only speak
French if you call for one we stayed
there late into the night that first
time eventually one of the restaurant
employees gave us a ride back to our car
on the other side of the track where we
oh you'd like stayed there for the whole
[ __ ] race huh well we got maybe a
couple hours of sleep anyways just had
to tell you about that that track is so
crazy compared to anything you'll see in
f1 it's definitely worth getting outside
of the main area whether you seek out
that spot or somewhere else just to get
an idea of how massive the track is and
see them doing 200 miles an hour down
dark country roads with just their
headlights to the track not sure if
you'll actually get this message before
I missed all of that I was on the main
straightaway and just looked like a
regular race track well I'll be like you
the second time around hopefully I'll
get it right
god damn it I didn't know there was all
of that rejection letters you know
what's crazy was there was a [ __ ]
airport like like parallel like right
almost touching the main straightaway
and I kept seeing these helicopters like
taking off and [ __ ] you know I thought
they were just following the race and
all of a sudden I saw like a [ __ ]
Learjet
flying right along where a helicopter
just been flying along I'm like there's
no way that's [ __ ] safe what is that
all about is that some rich guy just
going I don't give a [ __ ] I'm paying you
buzz the [ __ ] racetrack weave around
these [ __ ] helicopters you know but
turned out there was a there was a
airport right there anyway
anyway so is this one is this one I
should bring Leah in here for this one
reading rejection letters psycho bill
wondering if you saw this this
accomplished clarinet player was
accepted to his dream school but never
received the good news because his
then-girlfriend deleted it and sent him
a fake rejection email that turned out
to be a 265 thousand dollar mistake on
her part okay let's see what the [ __ ]
happened alright this kid his hard work
paid off the accomplished clarinet had
been accepted to his dream school but he
never got to hear the good news that's
because when his acceptance email
arrived in 2014 his then-girlfriend
deleted it and sent him a fake rejection
email from the school was at $265,000
mistake he said was really devastating
to feel that incredible betrayal and
maybe think of our whole relationship
and made me feel like everything might
have been a lie anywhere it began a
college sophomore studying music at
McGill University at the time this kid
had applied to a two-year full
scholarship program to finish his
bachelor's degree at the Colburn
Conservatory of Music in Los Angeles
hitching to study with a renowned
clarinet teacher so and so spent many
late nights in practice rooms to prepare
for his auditions which he thought went
well the full scholarship which includes
tuition room and board is worth about 50
grand a year and so and so said
graduating from Colburn would have sent
him up for hype set him up a high paying
Symphony career when he was rejected the
kid was crushed
it was disappointing feeling he said I
had such high hopes
the kid would would have studied with
this person who was considered one of
the best clarinet instructors in the
world he said the school accepts only
two students each year at Colburn and he
was one of them how she covered her
tracks this Wednesday a Canadian Court
ruled that this guy's ex-girlfriend
older more than two hundred sixty-five
thousand dollars three hundred fifty
grand Canadian for damages including
loss of reputation educational
opportunity and two years of potential
income roughly thirty seven thousand
dollars can you [ __ ] him can you believe
like the level of like break into his
eat like she'd had to be snowing that he
that letter is coming she had to be
constantly skipper so what she knows his
[ __ ] I guess computer passwords it's
just scanning it scanning saying finds
it sees that he gets accepted [ __ ]
deletes this guy's dream and then comes
up with the whole phony thing I don't
know I want to how the [ __ ] they found
out but this is why this dis whole
[ __ ] you know this me to [ __ ] now
whether just saying straight across the
board believe women when there's women
like that out there okay there's a
reason why that there's due process and
you have to have evidence and you have
to listen to both sides of the [ __ ]
story yet again another person was
accused this week and without this part
the person being accused without them
ever responding the does this stuff that
people wrote on Twitter I always knew
this person was a piece of [ __ ] I loved
one person was a [ __ ] most
self-serving thing ever if you're still
following so-and-so unfollow me right
like like wow man you're really sticking
up for women you're willing to look to
lose like [ __ ] Twitter followers way
to make a [ __ ] stand stop making it
about yourself you [ __ ] jerk-off
and I'm not saying anybody innocent
guilty or whatever
the reality is then the guy then
responds and says now look we argued and
bla bla bla bla bla and she ended up
being unfaithful to me and I didn't want
to be with somebody that one that was
unfaithful to me so then at that point I
just want to know like how did how does
anybody make a judgment any sane
rational person like you read her story
like wow man that's really [ __ ] up bla
bla bla bla bla and then you read his
things that well then there's that side
of it so then what you just now at that
point you've read two things online like
just imagine a quart of in a court of
law
somebody's like entire future was on the
line and the plaintiff and the defendant
all they were gonna do was write two
paragraphs of I don't know if you call
it a blog or whatever and then you were
gonna determine you know somebody's
ability to continue their career or not
is is a mic that's a little [ __ ] nuts
people and this is what's driving me up
the wall is I've been saying this it
shows and you know the vibe is people
[ __ ] agree with that but everybody's
afraid to say it so it's just I know
it's just not a this you know the [ __ ]
that guys have been doing women has to
[ __ ] stop but I don't think the way
to go about it is to just make blanket
statements of believe women like it's
like all of them even the ones who keep
people's cars and [ __ ] brake laptops
and destruction of property all of that
even the ones that [ __ ] you know are
out there saying that they love somebody
just because the guys got [ __ ] all of
them I don't know it's so it's a little
[ __ ] tough it's just such a [ __ ] I
never heard it I can't at all is I'm
just really surprised at how [ __ ]
just how afraid everybody is and I
everybody just chooses self-preservation
and they'll sit there and they'll watch
somebody twist in the wind you know cuz
there's been you know there's been
obviously this guy's a [ __ ] monster
this guy should be in jail and then
there's been some other ones like what
and it but everybody still shuts the
[ __ ] up while these lunatics on Twitter
alike you know [ __ ] burn them at the
stake I don't know I keep thinking that
eventually like it's it's gonna like
calm down a little bit where people are
gonna be like okay and what if that what
that woman wrote is true this needs to
happen why don't we all just hang on a
second and listen to what the guy has to
say and then even then all you've done
is just it that's like you show up at a
[ __ ] car accident and then both
drivers are pointing at each other and
you know and you weren't there when it
[ __ ] happened I don't know that's
another thing too when you watch all of
these like these these videos and [ __ ]
of you know injustice is happening what
I can't stand about those [ __ ] videos
is it always starts after for the most
part after the injustice happened and
it's one person's point of view on it
and everybody just watches it and acts
like they just saw a documentary or
actually just watch the footage from
beginning to end or maybe it isn't maybe
it's just a 30,000 [ __ ] lunatics on
on social media I have no idea but uh I
don't know like Nia showed me one the
other day and I was just watching going
like all right well what she's bitching
about I isn't on this the footage
it's just her yelling at the guy saying
why did you do that you didn't see him
do what she's saying that he did and
he's standing there defending himself
saying I didn't [ __ ] do it
but it's her video so her point of view
becomes what happened this is getting
confusing to me just trying to [ __ ]
explain it to you anyways alright 28
year old virgin hey Billie Billie built
Laster
I love the podcast and your raging
sanity I'm going to be honest I don't
think there's a solution to my problem
Wow come on man but just hearing you
talk about it might help me
see it as a so bad it's funny kind of
situation I'm a 28 year old virgin and
he rides a no Jesus I'm ugly as [ __ ] now
come on man accept even [ __ ] has dung
beetles that appreciate the aesthetic
all right so you got a sense of humor
self-deprecating
I got big-ass ears that lie
perpendicular to the side of my head big
triangle nose balding Island pattern
small island of hair on the forehead
with the rest of the hair in a horseshoe
pattern very hairy all over except my
[ __ ] head pointy ass man titties with
pepperoni nipples Jesus Christ and best
of all Maya genitals alone would send
any woman sprinting towards the horizon
side from that can't complain
respectable job good friends great
family bit heavy 5 9 160 pounds dude
that's not heavy but otherwise healthy I
try to stay upbeat but I as I get older
it really starts to weigh on me that I'm
destined to live life on as a solo
player any advice would be appreciated
wish you and your family all the best
yeah dude come on man you got to step up
to the plate all right you're you're
saying game over before you even play
the game all right you have a great
sense of humor I think you're being way
too hard on yourself
the fact that you say you're a bit heavy
at 5 9 160 you know I think you're being
you means to me that your prop yet
you're not heavy which means you're
probably not nearly as ugly as you're
saying yeah dude I would get out there I
would get out there there's dating apps
there's all kinds of [ __ ] you can do I
mean I you know you got any friends any
guy friends and just tell him you SPECT
dude I'm a 28 year old [ __ ] virgin
you got to help me out here
maybe that's not the way to go cuz guys
will [ __ ] be like try to just find
you some you know loose woman that's not
I don't think that's the way you want to
go but I yeah I would just you gotta you
got to get up to the plate too
you got to get up to the plate and you
have to stop looking at yourself the way
you're looking at yourself you gotta
keep that great sense of humor but you
know you're not ugly as [ __ ] okay dude
look at me okay
I'm a [ __ ] 50-year old bald redheaded
male and I think I look great
it's all how you look at yourself okay
but if you think you look good you feel
good about yourself it's a nice vibe to
[ __ ] have and you'll attract people
all right and just use your senses that
I've been number one thing you got going
for yourself is the type of fact you
still have your whole life ahead of you
you're only 21 28 years old you got a
great sense of humor women love to laugh
huh how do you think I landed Nia I made
a [ __ ] laugh sure as hell wasn't
coming from my [ __ ] looks I don't
know what it was
who the [ __ ] knows but if she knew 15
years later she'd be going to the 24
hours al-imam I don't think she would
have gone you landed me because I knew
about your earning potential that's it
what oh my god I knew anyone I was
making money when you met me no you
weren't yes I was I was on the rich
[ __ ] tour right but like you weren't
rich [ __ ] I was doing great
anyways yeah I never because I never
told you you never told me I didn't ask
I didn't care like it's just wow it's
amazing you just came in here and became
a hero hey can you help this guy out
he's a 28 year old virgin he said he's a
28 year old virgin that's fine
he goes I'm ugly as [ __ ] oh he goes
except even [ __ ] has dung beetles that
appreciate that the extent but you see
what you get but he's got a great sense
of humor he goes I got big ass
like perpendicular to the side of my
head big big triangle nose yeah what
about Adrien Brody you like him oh yeah
there you go got a big-ass Roman nose
balding Island pattern you know you got
the circle here with the horseshoe shave
it all off he's very hairy all over
except my [ __ ] head he goes pointy
ass man titties with pepperoni nipples
this sounds like Jim Norton wrote this
and best of all he goes my genitals
alone would send any woman sprinting
towards the horizon oh wow
alright so what does he do listen I I
know they say listen I know they say
that the man makes the clothes the
clothes don't make the man but I feel
like you know maybe you need to shave
that head bald like the way Bill has it
so you know there's no like trace
anytime that horseshoe starts to come
back you just slap some shaving cream on
it and go to town on that bad boy
wow that people think you know like MMA
or some [ __ ] wax your back because that
shit's nasty just waxing it just boom
just deal with it you'll be fine he's
already 60% better looking right there
yeah you know go to the gym you'll feel
never mind dude he's five nine 160s said
he says I'm a goes I'm a be sitting on
bit heavy five nine 160 doesn't sound
big to me that sounds maybe your doughy
maybe your fleshy fleshy maybe your
skinny fat like you know you don't have
any tone in your body yeah yeah not my
tempo not my scent beau he's what he
does he shaves his head shaves his head
he gets shredded no for the women shaky
head gets shredded just even going to
the gym you'll make him himself feel
better I mean I don't know what to do
about your dick size I mean I hope
you're eat out game is strong because so
what if he had like a 12
pack apps you get with a guy 12 pack abs
well eight pack would have a pack abs no
wait you let me finish with this
scenario 8 pack abs that you kissed down
that leads to his little fella down
there are you you'd be less disappointed
if you had the little [ __ ] xylophone
above it but you go to my help
maybe you should also like cut down your
pubes so your dick looks bigger his dick
isn't small 5 9 1 60p [ __ ] thinks
he's fat I bet his dick is fine
I don't know and that's fine that's what
I'm saying your eat out gay it better be
strong you eat out can your fingering
game all that stuff ass eating whatever
just I don't know what I don't know who
you are right now 12 pack left too
intimidating just go to the gym like not
everybody has to have washboard abs I
just you just [ __ ] told this guy that
you know all of these [ __ ] skills
like when you of course get laid all you
know they get a [ __ ] stick your
dinner and now you're doing all these
[ __ ] you know next level moves those
are all next level moves right I would
act out I wouldn't say fingering though
yeah that that's a pre that's the
prequel that's like the third Star Wars
right he knows where the [ __ ] is he'll
be fine right yeah I would think with
videos and [ __ ] everything on the
internet I think would be fine but don't
use porn as a guide pouring like I just
feel like porn [ __ ] guys up because
like you I'm not saying to use porn so
should he go to uh doc Lincoln Stein's
click binder wholesome clip finder what
if he
money and you get a nice professional
woman who can like help you with all
that that's not the ideal way to lose
your virginity but yeah are you saying
to get a hooker an escort what's never
seen a hooker in an escort I don't know
really but escort sounds nice chance of
STD well I mean you know the escorts
have like website venom oh it smell like
cash I mean I think cash is preferred I
mean listen hookers are outside like
those people when they try to get you to
go into the place to get your taxes done
out there flipping the signs around
exactly okay not that I have a problem
with street hookers either listen dad
dude you got to do but either seems a
little guidance a little self-esteem I
don't know I feel like this is weird
because it's like I'm promoting
prostitution yeah I think what I said
was a little more positive I said going
on dating sites and stuff like that I
mean you can use your sense of humor oh
yeah yeah yeah be good forget the
escorts did I say escorts I'm sorry no
because I you know to feel like sex
workers are fine whatever
yeah but what's this question he wants
to get laid yes he doesn't want to go
through life alone of course none of us
do you know nothing you wanna do the
last one here you're on a roll here yeah
yeah you're just [ __ ] killing it and
there's there's a level of coldness to
you today that's really funny oh yeah
what are you what are you over you over
the podcast or something no no II just
might cold this mr. friend's mom is a
psycho
mr. friends this sounds like a TV show
mr. friend's mom he's a psycho dear bill
I have a friend who's been getting
grounded a lot recently for the dumbest
[ __ ]
my friend's mom mr. mom I probably but I
like mr. friends mom better all my
friends have known for a while that his
mom was a psycho but now it's getting
way worse first he got grounded for a
month how old is this person wasn't
allowed to leave the house outside of
school at all because he got a 70 on one
test his grades are good not great but
better than 70% of the kids at my school
now just this past week he got grounded
for the entire summer for using his
laptop to text when he wasn't supposed
to be able to communicate with anybody
outside the house when he's not in
school he's 16 years old by the way is
there anything I could do could or
should do to help him or should I just
leave it alone you got to leave it alone
just be his friend and just commiserate
with him Wow
Nicki's grounded for the whole summer
down you can't leave the house or like
anything like that no I know what I
would do but I'm not giving a minor
advice yeah I'm gonna stay away from
this one he didn't say he said his
grades are good they're not great he's
kind of agreeing with you yeah he's just
saying that's not justification one text
message you can't go out the whole
summer what does he know about parenting
or any of that you're too young do you
think so you think that's a fair got a
70 on a test to ground them no I don't
communicate with your friends outside of
school and then he sent one text message
or whatever and now he can't go up with
all summer
that's definitely extreme I don't think
that I would parent like that but that's
not my kid and I don't know what else
he's doing acidy know if it was just one
text he sent one text yet what was the
text about really we're leaving that
alone Oh
what does it say one minute and 26 27
okay that's one hour one hour twenty you
think we've done a minute we did a
minute on this podcast me
okay what a minute yeah you said I said
how much time I've done you said one
minute one hour okay cool
all right well that's yeah that's the
podcast yeah I've had such a wonderful
time here with you that's right that's
right baby
like how special is that I told you I
was in the kitchen I was like cleaning
up and I was looking over at her playing
in the living room and I was like I know
I was making her dinner I was like I'm
making dinner for my little baby girl
and parent like it's just it's so
special so how cool when she says a
French word oh say weed she goes we we
imitate oh and she says I say thanks she
nods her head she asks for food you go
what are you saying she goes free and
then he give it to you now you're saying
she goes Thanks she nods her whole head
like a bad commercial for the 1950s it's
the cutest thing ever
anyways that's it merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Perry of wah was a bone
we had a great time and that's it and
thank you once again to Tom Rhodes for
letting me know about that party sorry
all you just had the pistachio macaroon
you gotta have those sandwiches I got I
got the [ __ ] John Boehner avec
fromage well no I gave you a half of
each thing and I got a salmon one there
like punch the wall good [ __ ]
incredible
alright that's the podcast oh I gotta
say it in French I'm gonna I gotta say I
keep forgetting how to say go [ __ ]
yourselves
I keep forget how does say go [ __ ]
yourself on frozen var2 fare uncool a
I'll I'll check in on you on Thursday
[ __ ] do I shut it on